some locals like it casual while others
prefer a little more style Barcelona is
the kind of city where people dress to
impress just differently the body gothic
the artists quarter in the center of the
old town is now home to a range of small
boutiques designer Crete CRO boo Stella
set up restore here four years ago
complete with tailoring workshop she
founded her own label shortly after
graduating from college I mean if you go
on this day brings ep.1 at the beginning
fashion for me meant a different form of
art expression for my exposure different
it was young but as the years went by I
noticed that was more of a business baby
Gator for this reason I believe fashion
is a meeting point between art and
business which is what people buy and
where el arte que mis del cuerpo y que
es lo que la gente y baloch re creatures
designs are wild but wearable glamorous
and at the same time easygoing the
designer plays consciously with these
contrasts she wants her customers to
have fun with their products the clothes
should make people smile she combines
cotton with upscale materials like silk
making quality clothes at affordable
prices is a key part of our concept the
items cost between 30 and 200 euros no
tenemos la marca como por the lokes case
on babe deluxe is a combination of
sportswear style and luxurious details
that give it a more fashionable feeling
and it's applied to the street style
idea yep lekar low low on Brenda's coma
eventually a journalist to find the
brand is 40 bucks a pair adista ed
finial estilo como score deluxe ii
nosotros lo propio Mo's
every year creature of Estella creates
two collections designed and made in
Barcelona she starts out with a ladies
wear collection in fact a lot of men
then bought the clothes and retailored
them for themselves that gave Robustelli
the motivation to design menswear as
with her products for women she was
clearly not afraid of using daring
colors and patterns ella Feliciana
segregate muy importante loaded IE
details by an important part in our
collections given that each collection
has a different theme into this end and
the most themes are very important for
us and we try to explain each theme
through details for example the prints
and fabrics is plenty o en los en los
tejidos euros estan pados the 28 year
olds main inspiration is life itself and
the world around her a stroll through
her neighbourhood is always productive
the body go taken del born districts are
the pulsating harder Barcelona's
creative scene and a continuous source
of ideas for the designer hey Rafael una
mentira como fue de porque tiene
Barcelona inspires me as a city because
it has mountains and a beach close by
with all the info you can see a lot of
things in a short period of time get'em
where there are many people from
different countries from other
communities in Spain which makes it
easier to work with people I think about
the fact that everything is so close
gives us many opportunities ok I moved
up to lead out
not far away from the goethe quarter or
the city's most famous shopping drags La
Rambla and passage de grazia all the
major Spanish clothing chains are
represented here locals are particularly
proud of the Cousteau Barcelona brand
the vibrant colors and playful designs
reflect the upbeat mentality in the
Catalonian capital the label is
associated with an eccentric style and
now has fans worldwide behind la oficina
in kelowna just because of the warm
weather people in Barcelona liked using
a lot of colors in their wardrobe the
way people dress in Barcelona is very
different from how they dress in Madrid
having a beach in Barcelona makes our
style more hip you like it's that cool
and casual attitude that defines
Barcelona's hip reputation and the
popularity of its laid-back fashion
designers